what is up gamers we have a giant
roulette wheel and 100 minecraft players
trapped in the middle here's how it work
but what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
open the gates
which allows them to pick a number so
I'm gonna lock the gates and if they're
not in a number they're dead Carl and
Chandler are also both playing now the
gates are locked everyone here that has
not picked a number is defiant I'm sorry
for everyone that's about to die and
that is all the rules good luck you can
win $10,000 also if you're ever caught
hacking in any of my videos you are
permanently banned from our server now
I'm gonna roll the wheel the number is 5
let's go let's go not 10 not two
oh my goodness there's a lot of people
oh no a PewDiePie skin no poor Jedi
oh no way Jedi no he knows he's about to
die too he's the first person to ever
win 10 grand on this channel before I
kill you Jedi what did you spend the 10
grand on nothing yet before you if I
give you a nine steak can I can I get
mercy for no sorry bye I was about to
say I'll give you 64 steak to not give
him mercy can I fill the entire area
with lava and watch them slowly die if
that's what brings your heart desires
zone 5 sorry but the wheel picked you
you must go just got takes he's smart
look at him go oh wait this guy's sad
because of it you want some bud thank
you what's up good what was your what
time you want to celebrate entertain I'm
gonna open up the gates and I'm gonna
let him pick a new number all right I'm
about to close the gates let's see if
anyone gets locked out uh squid oh it's
good man bossy all you had to do was
pick a gate you didn't even give
yourself a chance at 10 grand he's gone
and we're gonna spin the wheel do to do
boom oh my god that's the one I was at
last time I say this time we murdered
them with creepers oh man he's just
taking it like a man oh man run boy yo
we should we should have some creepers
out here just to spice it up all right I
added enough you don't need add I had
one this one's name is Bill all right
I'm gonna unlock the gates opening the
gates this is extra deadly look at Ahmad
they're so scared of the creepers
I'm going to 16 going to 3 carlos trying
to get in 16 oh I'm dying
pull up hey Chris Chris Chris yeah I'm
gonna spawn a creeper behind Carl watch
this watch this he doesn't see it he
didn't tall doesn't see it coming ha ha
got him
chris is trying to bamboozle me all
right I'm gonna go close to gates whoa I
was so close to the gay all right let's
go roll the dice boom
11 you that's a three for three baby
here's what I'm gonna do Chris here's
the wooden sword they're toying with
them here's a wooden sword they're
toying with a hammer
here's a wooden sword fight to the dead
whoever's last standing gets to survive
entertain me oh look at that going in
for it really early all you see is just
sitting in the corner this PvP could win
them 10 grand the action is exciting we
gotta kill all right here we go he is
hitting a block yeah he missed
completely we got it we're just gonna
kind of peruse u1e battle royale GG you
get a second life all right opening the
gates all right pick a new number boys
perfectly between 16 and 3 locking the
gates Oh Chris Oh what he's stuck in the
gate he's stuck in the gate how do we
count this Oh
all right he's good hope I found
Chandler he's over here here's a creeper
Chandler what all right that was all I
bet he's freaking out they didn't even
roll away all right what number is it 10
Chris I'm gonna put you in charge of
opening the gate all right I'm gonna do
it fast I'm angry I'm trusting you
Chandler okay cop I think we're good go
for it all right I'm locking the gates
three two one locked oh my gosh she may
barely made it
here you know what we should give him a
second chance sleep all right I got the
wheel
spinning nine oh dude I swear a lot of
people are just going to whatever the
last number was we should act like we
don't see that guy in the corner okay
and that should be everybody right Jimmy
look they're all pointy to him in the
corner go open the gates and as soon as
you do I'm gonna kill him opening the
gates right now oh no he was jumping
into it we have three stragglers for
stragglers this guy Steve Harvey assist
kid what is this honestly for that skin
I think we spare him
are you guys happy with what we're about
to do we're gonna do it right in front
of you you want to watch this person not
be alive anymore
gabie gabie gabie their body all right
let's roll the wheel you want me to roll
up for oh I love how you started backing
up like he was scared he did watch it if
I come over there get real scared he
doesn't eat years no man I love this
maybe he should fear a man to speed
things up every time it picks a number
from here on out we're filling it with
love for both oh whoa baby this ain't
Wendy's oh you mean Oh all right spend
the wheel rolling the wheel 1500 yeah
that's it Chandler Carl no way we
finally got away Oh beloved antler get
back in there wait Carl's killing
everybody Carl why did you kill
everybody because I don't know what you
guys know baby I'm sorry Bernie baby
knows he had to be put down I'm sorry
Carl
you evil menace you want to know
something what I was gonna have you to
duel to the death and let one of you
survive but no you guys had to go rogue
if you wanted to kill 3d baby yeah I
don't want you to get this satisfaction
Jimmy all right I'm gonna open the gates
they're all going after one person
follow this poor boy
all right let's lock the gates and roll
the wheel 14 I'm gonna kill this guy
because he's a chicken all right oh look
at that you can't swim in lava you idiot
what a dingus
why would he not just double tap space
and slide
oh my goodness Jimmy permission to kill
sands real quick what I'm feeling is the
ravager shall decide their fate
whoever's left standing last good it's
going only after saying why don't you
exceedance kill no hero I had some lava
into the mix to to like make it
interesting
Oh who was he going for No Oh Gillis
Mart he used the lava to his advantage
he was nasty always training it around
the lava let's go
what a genius he's really like Gila in
the anime he's using his brain oh my
goodness and they both survived but I
still have to cover this place in love
with Tila watch out yo go can I roll the
wheel nine
Marcus the person is this Marcus Pierson
no oh then he can just start all right
bend it again three lava I'm up all
right here's what we're gonna do we're
gonna let the Revengers decide I'm gonna
go ahead and start filling this with
lava the Ravagers have spoken none shall
rear o thirteen uh in the main show I
spent 24 hours in solitary confinement
and I had to wear this orange suit and
it sucked
so since he also has an orange suit on
I'm gonna spare him if he can survive
two creepers all right he gets open the
gates
oh you locked this creeper out he was
going over there he was trying to get in
nine ah no I'm gonna let them commit
sudoku themselves you know the deal get
in by hey jump to get in the fire Steve
Steve I don't want to do this
get in fifteen people remain and $10,000
is still on the large jerks who is still
in this it jerks who wins that means
this can be a second time winning
$10,000 on this channel jerks who has a
sword or are you giving them weapons no
now in the next few minutes we're gonna
find out which one of these people won
ten smackeroonies let's roll the dice
one oh sure soon you may have won
$10,000 in a previous video but you did
not win $10,000 today but at least I
have one 10k that's big at least I have
$10,000 here Jimmy take a look at this
son yeah this lava pit is reserved for
people who have won $10,000 if I don't
sue Oh creepers are doing some business
aw man Chris I think you went a little
to him with the papers I think I did the
perfect amount 5 stones for me hit it
11 there are exactly 10 people left oh
it's killer
all right you know it's time I grew up
and I stopped giving people an anime
skins favoritism I did it for you I knew
you couldn't do that spin the wheel
oh no sucksby you know 10 grand for you
know 10 grand for you open the gates
there's 5 people here and there's two
people there there are seven people that
remain but only one $10,000 no more
covering zones and lava close the gates
good luck spin the wheel yes
ding-ding-ding so my fix my lava mistake
I forgot not to do lava fix my mistakes
for me right to the dip entertain us
oh they're just ganging up on him oh
that wasn't right they just ganged up on
him
this guy is stuck oh well congrats you
are now one step closer to $10,000 there
are five people left open the gates
Chandler he's making a - he's making a -
lock the gates there's so many people
that have won money from this video amid
you won $5,000 and the dueling to the
death video yeah that's true and now
you're this close to winning $10,000
people are gonna think this is rigged if
you won two challenges but who cares
because they're not just you guys no one
of you are walking away with $10,000
spin the wheel oh well you know what
they say you can't win them all bored or
you were so close to winning ten grand
what do you want to say I just fine
maybe next a bit you'll win enough money
to buy a car admit I'd feel bad but you
already won money so the two people that
remain is Alan and zoffie instead of
letting the roulette wheel decide I
think we have some fun here's what we're
doing look both of you look at me I'm
holding up a hand I'm holding up either
one or two Jurassic which number do you
think I'm holding up if you pick the
wrong number you lose $10,000 um
probably one Alan do you think I'm
holding a two or one - my hand has been
in front of the camera the whole time
and the number I'm holding is - no way
sorry we need you to come over here this
is the pit for one alan gamer gross six
nine eight three you just won $10,000
Allen how old are you I'm thirsty and
unisom won $10,000 you have a deeper
voice and Carl which one has the most
lava got it thank you everybody for
watching this mr. beast gaming video
make sure you subscribe and we'll see
you next time